[Musique]
salut les garçons
salut Johanna salut Christian salut Marc
salut Marc salut Christian salut Johanna
salut Nico
et Johanna je savais que cette vidéo est
sponsorisée par Nord VPN quoi avec
nordvpn tu peux te protéger contre
toutes les menaces comme le sida mais
non enfin
dommage ne t'inquiète pas Johanna il te
reste du temps et la médecine peut
encore progresser
ainsi tu le prends tes jeux de toutes
les tentatives de piratage de tes
données personnelles ouais moi aussi je
déteste les pirates dans les aéroports
tu peux aussi te déplacer dans un autre
pays et regardez des contenus bloqués
sans être vu et avec Nord-Pas plus
besoin de te souvenir de tous les mots
de passe long et fastidieux tu peux
mémoriser et protéger tous les mots de
passe d'un seul clic enfin j'aurai plus
besoin de me souvenir de mon mot de
passe
c'est une super nouvelle les garçons
allez on chante
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est le top de la beauté que si
vous protège des pirates
un sujet de chanson moins spécifique que
ça notre groupe marcherait mieux
obtenez nordvpn et Nord-Pas au meilleur
prix en passant par le lien en
description
[Applaudissements]
et maintenant retrouvons une nouvelle
histoire de papy grenier
dedans et pas censé être en train de
travailler depuis la réforme sur la
retraite à 87 ans
depuis la réforme sur le travail des
mineurs oui c'est vrai ouais bon ben
écoutez vous dites rien je dis rien
tiens prenez une clope
[Musique]
raconte une histoire une histoire est-ce
que je vous ai déjà montré cette vidéo
avec Johnny Hallyday qui chante le
générique de Pokémon
est devenu président du bunker
maintenant
est-ce que je vous ai déjà parlé de la
fois où j'étais dans un lycée magique
c'était en 2023 et à cette époque
personne n'imaginait que le fandom de
Harry Potter allait devenir une secte
religieuse
j'étais un de mes profs qui
m'accompagnait jusqu'au lycée parce que
j'étais rentré directement en cinquième
année de magie j'avais sauté plein de
clash j'étais super balaise
magique après on s'était fait attaquer
par un dragon il y a de mes profs qui
s'est fait tuer devant mes yeux on est
tombé dans le vide et j'ai commencé à
avoir des chevaux démoniaques que tu
vois normalement que quand tu frôles la
mort ensuite on a escaladé des falaises
en Écosse on est passé à la banque on a
croisé un criminel de guerre on s'est
battu contre des statuts géantes ah oui
on est allé à l'école aussi après
j'étais à peine 8h30 le jour de leur
entrée et j'avais déjà failli mourir 8
fois en même temps moi qui venais d'un
collège public ça a changé pas beaucoup
quand on est arrivé on a commencé par la
cérémonie du choix des maisons le
Choixpeau avait la capacité de voir en
toi il pouvait sonder ton âme pour te
placer dans l'école qui te correspondait
le plus grâce à des questions
extrêmement précises vous aviez
certaines attentes en venant ici
des préférences et des préjugés
[Musique]
ou banane
je sais pas moi banane
mais attends papi c'était tout ton
avenir à Poudlard qui dépendait de ce
moment
c'était moins sévère que ce qu'on
pouvait penser ah non Serdaigle ça fait
chier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
moi qui décide personne ne peut décider
à ma place après la cérémonie j'avais
rencontré Sébastien un autre
élève de ma classe qui m'avait proposé
d'aller acheter mon matériel dans le
village d'à côté
mais j'imagine que la plupart des gens
tu vas pas faire ça pendant ton trajet
et finalement au bout de quelques
minutes de marche nous sommes arrivés
après au lard ah il n'y a rien de plus
beau que préaulard tu vas pas répéter ça
à chaque fois qu'on vient ici prêt au
leurre c'était là où se trouvait le
célèbre magasin d'olivander le meilleur
vendeur de baguette de toute la région
j'allais devoir choisir ma baguette avec
soin car elle serait mon compagnon pour
la vie comme on dit c'est pas le sorcier
qui choisit sa baguette c'est la
baguette qui choisit son sorcier
et enfin sauf pour la couleur la taille
la rigidité l'objet magique qui a dedans
le type de bois aussi bon vous voulez
quoi du chêne du Noyer de la cagette 20
cm 30 plutôt flexible ou du vous savez
moi je m'en fous hein je sais pas plutôt
30 cm bien dur
c'est marrant ça me l'avait jamais fait
dis donc sinon dedans je mets quoi plus
de Phoenix craint de licorne je sais pas
ça change quoi rien de toute façon vous
n'avez pas besoin de baguettes pour
faire de la magie
dehors plutôt
là il n'y a rien de plus beau que prior
c'est ça ça fait 200 balles je vous mets
McFlurry avec
under c'était très certainement le
meilleur dans son métier peut-être parce
que c'était le seul aussi tenez essayez
cette baguette
[Musique]
celle-là alors
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
maintenant que j'avais mon bout de bois
magique il était temps d'aller à
Poudlard défendre les couleurs de ma
maison quel plaisir de sentir qu'on ne
fait qu'un avec son lycée avec sa maison
avec nos uniformes tous identiques on ne
formait qu'un seul et véritable clan et
il faut savoir que j'étais pas comme
tous les autres lavages détenais en moi
une magie très puissante et il fallait
savoir l'utiliser de manière raisonnable
après évidemment ça c'était pendant les
promenades le résultat j'allais en cours
comme tout le monde et maintenant je
vais vous apprendre une seule duo mais
enfin mesdames c'est pas trop dangereux
pour de simples lycéens comme nous
[Musique]
mais ce pouvoir c'était
pas
au collège quand même j'étais grand et
les sorciers plus que tout autre doivent
être des gens responsables et se servir
de leur pouvoir magique uniquement pour
la justice
[Musique]
je t'ai enfin rattrapé et je vais te
faire des choses méchantes parce que je
suis méchant et que j'aime faire du mal
aux Antilles
et que ça te servent de leçon
effectivement ça a marché il a jamais
recommencé bon alors pour le lycée comme
je dis je rentrais en 5e année donc
j'avais 5 ans de retard sur mes
collègues je pensais que ça allait être
dur à rattraper mais au final ça va les
cours dans le lycée de campagne c'est
pas trop dur maintenant nous allons
apprendre le sort action
et répéter après moi action
voilà le correcteur terminé allez on va
dehors pour jouer à la pétanque mais
papi ça avait l'air facile à magie non
non attendez on avait quand même 26 ans
à apprendre et on avait que cette année
pour tous les apprendre ça fait combien
par année
votre cours de maths oui ça fait
beaucoup et puis il y avait des couleurs
à retenir s'il y avait un bouclier jaune
fallait mettre un sort jeune si c'était
un bouclier rouge il fallait mettre un
sort rouge et ainsi de suite il y avait
quand même quatre couleurs ça fait
beaucoup 4 couleurs vous croyez que
c'est facile peut-être et les autres
élèves de la classe ils étaient sympas
papi les autres lèvres ils étaient
spéciaux il y avait de tout il y avait
la meuf qui est au lycée avec un
physique d'élèves de primaire et qui
jouent encore aux billes il y avait
l'aveugle qui fait semblant d'être
aveugle
on lui disait rien parce qu'il était
sympa il y avait l'étudiant de
Serpentard chez qui m'emmenait dans des
endroits bizarres mais je vais pas vous
mentir c'était une classe atypique ça
dirait d'aller dans un endroit on a pas
le droit d'aller hey ça te dirait de
m'aider à fabriquer de l'alcool
illégalement ça te dirait de rejoindre
un club de duel secret où on fait
s'affronter des enfants ça te dirait
d'apprendre un soir pour
assassiner les gens mais papi c'était
autorisé c'est ça
tous des sorcières raisonnables on
savait se gérer enfin c'est terrible
jour en 2005 où il y a eu un petit
incident un peu de la pourtant c'était
un Serpentard on aurait dû le voir venir
mais bref c'est dramatique parlons
d'autre chose le seul fille un peu
normal de ma classe c'était natsuy
online c'était une élève qui venait
d'une école de magie en Ouganda
d'ailleurs là-bas il faisait de la magie
sans baguettes je savais même pas que
c'était possible mais les sorts sont les
mêmes là-bas
en grande partie oui mais j'ai dû
apprendre à me servir d'une baguette en
venant ici personne ne presque n'en
utilise à Ouagadougou je trouve la magie
sans baguette plus intuitive tu peux
lancer des sorts sans baguettes bien sûr
elle était sympa alors ça me faisait
toujours plaisir de discuter et
d'échanger sur nos cultures avec elle ah
oui nous aussi on a des gens qui font de
la magie sans baguette ici alors c'est
des elfes mais on appelle plutôt ça des
elfes maison entre nous parce qu'ils
vivent dans les sous-sols des maisons ou
dans les sous-sols du château ils
dorment dans des toutes petites cages
c'est trop mignon ils sont complètement
obligé de faire tout ce qu'on leur
demande là par exemple à Poudlard c'est
eux qui font le ménage la cuisine
c'est-à-dire croiser c'est ceux qui sont
habillés avec des des des drapsals
c'est un peu comme nous nos esclaves en
fait
chez vous sinon vous utilisez des
baguettes enfin je veux dire pour la
magie
debout debout
et sinon papy il y avait quoi d'autre
comme cours
différents en plus de la pétanque et du
cours de vol il y avait la botanique on
risque de mourir il y avait le cours de
potion on risque de mourir il y avait le
cours de duel on se battait contre les
autres élèves
c'était le cours du premier jour et on
risque de mourir la Gigi il y avait le
cours avec les animaux là la nature
autour de Poudlard était rempli
d'animaux fantastiques ils vivaient
tranquillement mais il y avait aussi
quelques braconniers c'est pour ça que
nelF de maison m'avait donné un sac
magique qui me permettait de les
protéger du coup j'adorais me promener
dans la nature pour trouver des animaux
à protéger je protégeais les mers les
enfants ensuite je les ramené dans leur
nouveau foyer où ils étaient heureux ils
rencontraient des nouveaux amis je leur
servais une nourriture diverses variée
et puis aussi parfois il me donnait
gentiment des ressources qui me
permettaient d'améliorer mon matériel
j'ai besoin d'améliorer mon avatar
et quand j'avais plus besoin de je l'ai
forcé à se reproduire et je les
revendais dans un magasin papi capturer
des animaux pour les revendre après
c'est pas la définition qui braconnage
c'est pour ça que je l'ai vide la
confiance et Papi vous aviez pas des
cours classiques de l'histoire-géo du
français tu crois que ça servir quelque
chose on n'avait pas le temps pour ça il
y avait tout un monde à découvrir le
monde autour de Poudlard était
magnifique avec tous ces ballons
dégueulasse qui gênaient la vue qu'on
avait mis juste pour moi en fait ces
obstacles naturels ces villages qui
prospérés grâce à la magie c'est donjons
qui étaient remplis de trésors
ancestraux à découvrir
[Musique]
un immense coffre au trésor oh un
chapeau de magie très ancienne et oh des
lunettes ayant appartenu à Merlin le
plus sage des magiciens
[Musique]
et parfois même ça arrivait qu'on puisse
trouver des objets inconnus alors il
fallait que je retourne chez moi pour
analyser ça et ben en fait il se trouve
que près analyse ce chapeau était un
chapeau
et voilà
et tu savais que tous les chemins mènent
à priolar et sinon il y avait quoi
d'autre à explorer dehors
depuis longtemps
et seul un élu de la force magique comme
moi véritable héritier de Merlin
possédait la ruse la puissance magique
et l'intelligence nécessaire pour en
venir à bout
[Musique]
j'ai enfin réussi cette épreuve je suis
clairement le descendant de Merlin
j'aurais aimé le connaître Merlin ça
avait l'air d'être un sacré personnage
alors là j'ai une épreuve magique qui
s'appelle the floor is lava en gros il
faut sauter sur des pieds sans jamais
toucher le sol et Monsieur c'est pas une
épreuve magique ça ah oui merde la magie
alors j'ai une autre idée ça s'appelle
Triki bille il faut mettre la grosse
boule dans le trou les bras de Merlin ne
me résisteront pas mais monsieur c'est
toujours pas une épreuve magique en fait
et gagneront quoi les futurs magiciens
qui ont réussi à faire toutes vos
épreuves à sort ultime un artefact très
puissant le plus puissant de tous les
artefacts
en gros sac
voilà regardez regardez-moi ça regardez
toutes ces poches franchement je
pourrais mettre toutes mes lunettes de
soleil dedans et honnêtement deux ou
trois écharpe de plus qu'un sac normal
c'est pas dégueulasse
[Musique]
les épreuves de Merlin j'ai passé des
heures à fouiller la campagne pour faire
ça le plus dur c'est quand on devait les
faire sur le territoire moldus et donc
nous voici arrivés au fameux menhirs de
Merlin une pierre vieille de 2000 ans
alors on ne sait pas vraiment quel était
son utilité mais non c'est
bon
boutique
souvenirs
[Musique]
des châteaux à explorer des villages à
visiter ou à revisiter réveillez tu es à
moi de midi c'est incroyablement pénible
avant que j'invente la poudre de cheval
et si tu prononces encore une fois le
mot préaulard je veux plus qu'un
plomberie le plus bel endroit du monde
et visiter tous ces villages c'était
aussi l'occasion pour moi d'utiliser les
nouveaux sorts que j'avais appris
pendant mes deux heures de cours
hebdomadaire
alors
omora
[Musique]
mais papi c'est pas un cambriolage ça
a été compréhensifs mais qu'est-ce que
vous foutez chez moi
alors en fait j'étais en train de dormir
par terre chez vous parce que en fait je
voudrais bien vous voler cette statue là
le problème c'est que je peux pas la
voler le jour je suis obligé de la voler
la nuit donc si vous pouviez juste faire
mal à la porte en partant
les pas un coussin mais sinon papi
comment ça c'est fini tout ça
de dirigé par Skyrock qui est complice
avec un type qui s'appelle Eastwood et
puis il y a une grosse salle de magie
avec des mecs dans des tableaux et des
anciens professeurs de magie anciennes
ou je sais pas quoi là non et j'en sais
rien j'ai laissé tomber comme tout le
monde la seule chose dont je me
souvienne c'est des araignée et tes
épreuves de Merlin et des millions
d'araignées et des épreuves de Merlin
partout il n'y a que ça devant mes yeux
mais papi c'est pas une histoire ça
c'est un jeu vidéo
j'ai encore le t-shirt comment elle est
seule à la fin de mes études
[Musique]
ça explique bien des choses pour ma
classe alors attendez de ma classe
j'étais dedans aussi du coup
bien sûr mais ce sera pour la prochaine
fois
[Musique]
et un remerciement tout particulier au
château du rocher portail en Bretagne
c'est pas trop loin de chez nous à
Fougères qui nous ont permis de tourner
dans des décors magnifiques il propose
trois événements autour de la nouvelle
école des sorciers et le prochain aura
lieu à la Toussaint pour une après-midi
ou une soirée vous serez plongée dans
une visite immersive ou vos professeurs
en plus de vous faire des démonstrations
de magie vous guideront pour résoudre
une énigme qui vous mènera jusqu'à la
crypto trésor alors rejoignez les
professeurs de l'école pour défendre le
rocher portail toutes les infos sont sur
leur site internet
[Musique]